well guys some big humongous news has
come about and I've gotten a lot of
tweets and messages about it a lot of
people have wondered my opinion Wonder
Woman is officially a person in movies
finally do you know how long they've
been trying to figure out a way to make
Wonder Woman involved in something they
even tried a second live-action TV show
recently and it didn't even make it on
air Wonder Woman has officially been
cast in the Batman vs Superman film or
Man of Steel 2 directed by Zack Snyder
she's gonna be portrayed by gal gadot of
fast and furious Fame now I'd like
during the Fast & Furious movies I think
that she's a fun presence in those
movies her character was enjoyable to
watch she was badass she was pretty cool
in those movies can she be Wonder Woman
a lot of people are speculating because
as I mentioned in my video about Ben
Affleck being Batman everyone always
hates everything that has ever announced
ever it doesn't matter what it is
generally people think that's a horrible
idea I hate it with the Ben Affleck
thing I thought a lot of the complaints
were unwarranted I understand the whole
thing I've made a video about it we
don't have to talk about that with this
one there are some complaints that I am
also a little worried about now don't
get me wrong I bought her as a
physically commanding person in The Fast
and the Furious movies that aspect I'm
not too worried about there are certain
things though that do concern me and I'm
having a bit of a hard time figuring out
how to say them because I try to be a
nice guy I really do so I'm actually
just gonna read to you what I wrote in
my notes because I've started to take
notes for my videos this is what I wrote
figure out a way to comment on her
physicality without being a dick Wonder
Woman in the comics is very tall like
six feet tall or something there's
various incarnations of her she's huge
she is huge in every way she's huge if
you know what I mean every way her legs
her chest her biceps her deltoids
everything about her is humongous she is
essentially a bodybuilding woman I mean
the only way you could actually get an
actress who actually resembled her is to
get a woman who is a bodybuilder and
that would just be so distracting it's
really the same with Superman you know I
mean there's never actually been an
actor who portrayed Superman in the
films who looked as buff as he does in
the comics because everything's more
exaggerated in the comics that being
said gal gadot is frail to say the least
she is gonna have to put on a lot of
muscle to
be able to be convincing as Wonder Woman
my best example would be to look at
Jennifer Gardner in Electra crappy
crappy movie but her form and her frame
fit out the character very well and I
think if gal gadot could work out to the
point where she looked like Jennifer
Gardner's basic frame and Elektra the
muscles the shoulders the legs and
everything then that would be a
convincing enough one a woman for me
because obviously they're trying to go
for a more realistic take on the
character it is not impossible for
actors and actresses to gain muscle for
a role I mean look at Christian Bale in
Batman he went from The Machinist where
he was essentially a stick all the way
to Batman Begins where he's probably
never been bigger than that in his
entire life this is a bit of a difficult
character I think to translate to film
seriously because she's really cool in
the comics but really the lasso of truth
the tiara of telepathy you know these
are various things that Wonder Woman can
do and it just sounds cheesy when you
say it in real life so who knows which
direction they'll take there are certain
ways that she is portrayed in the comics
there's her alter ego Diana Prince the
identity that she actually purchased off
of another woman who wanted to move away
she took that woman's identity and
became an Air Force secretary an Army
nurse that's a pretty badass portrayal
of a real-life type Wonder Woman they
would probably fit in to the world that
Zack Snyder has already created with Man
of Steel and as we already know Batman
and Superman will be in this film and
there are various incarnations of our
Wonder Woman is included with those two
men in various comics it happens quite
often actually there's even one where
this guy named Maxwell Lord is like
controlling Superman to kill Batman and
Wonder Woman has to try to intervene I
wonder if they'll go in a direction like
that I don't really know if they will
we'll have to see I think what they're
gonna do with the character of Wonder
Woman is probably something similar to
what they did with Black Widow and Iron
Man - she will be there she'll be a cool
character she Mabel have like one really
awesome badass scene and I don't know
she'll be as integral to the story as
Batman and Superman are because they
need to have her in there for Justice
League in 2017 they had to do that with
Black Widow and Iron Man - so if she
could be a part of the Avengers so I
think that's what they're trying to do
is figure out a way to include some of
these supporting characters of the
Justice League in these necks coming
films so they can have them in the
Justice League movie they probably won't
have her be like this humongous part
otherwise it would be Batman Superman
and Wonder Woman which would be a stupid
title now as I said more than
important things about really any
superhero but especially Wonder Woman is
gonna be the way she looks because that
costume is you know let's face it it's
very sexy and it's gonna be a
distracting as hell if she's running
around wearing blue underwear and
nothing on here and looks essentially
like a stripper there are various
different costumes that would look
really good for her one of the ones that
I think is very cool
was in the recent DC animated film the
flashpoint paradox she had all this
armor on it looked really cool and that
is definitely something that I think
Zack Snyder likes because he went for
the whole armor look with Zod and I
think that that is a way to portray the
kind of badassery that Wonder Woman is
without making her just be a sex object
there are always going to be fanboy
complaints and people who are like well
it has to be this way it has to be that
way because this is how I grew up with
it this is how the comics or the
cartoons or the films that I saw this is
how it affected me so I feel that it
should be this way because this is how I
feel it should be and anything regarding
comic book adaptations to film or
television are always surrounded around
those people's ideas of what they think
it should be but the basics of what
Wonder Woman should be is a tall woman
and this actress is 5 foot 9 add some
heels or some boots with some inches
she's gonna look like about 6 foot which
is a valid Wonder Woman is Wonder Woman
is buff she's an Amazon goddess of Greek
mythology so there's gonna have to be
some elements to the way that her voice
sounds that would make Wonder Woman seem
more like Wonder Woman but there is that
whole section of the comics as I
mentioned where she was Diana Prince
this army nurse Air Force secretary
that's very more grounded in reality
character that I think would probably
work better for they Batman vs Superman
movie all she really has to do in my
opinion is get buffer because I'm glad
let's just say I'm glad it's not some
woman with like double D breasts or
something basically like you wouldn't be
able to focus the entire time you just
be like oh this is oh there's Batman
there's Wonder Woman
oh hey Batman you're awesome oh hey
Superman yeah Wonder Woman so I can
understand why they went for an actress
that wasn't more you know you know I'm
getting that it was probably a good idea
but some fans will be disappointed by
that of course so all in all I am of
course optimistic about what these
people can do to bring together an
awesome character
assembling and make a really cool movie
and I hope that it works out what are
your guys thoughts on the casting of
Wonder Woman
let me know below sound off in the
comments say whatever you want it's cool
as always guys thanks a lot for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck my nice
[Music]